This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。绝对真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个节目聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全展开的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，收听《Learn the Hardway》
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.|||请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你在很大程度上两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。大批互联网侦探花了一番功夫才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.|||我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.|||我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身以及培养恢复力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是 TWO.%，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Okay, have you ever had that feeling, that sensation, that panic, that everybody is further ahead in their lives than you are. They are more successful,
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Okay, have you ever had that feeling, that sensation, that panic, that everybody is further ahead in their lives than you are. They are more successful,|||我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝，请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们二十多岁时遇到的重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴大家能回来收听新的一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析二十多岁的心理学。好吧，你是否曾有过那种感觉、那种体验、那种恐慌，觉得所有人在生活中的进度都比你超前。他们更成功，
they are more sure of themselves. They are further along when it comes to their relationships, their finances, knowing what they want to do with their lives. This feeling of being behind is a really common one during this decade, during our 20s. It is the norm, not the exception. But I think despite that, it's also incredibly stressful and at times debilitating. when we, A, don't have open conversations about it, there isn't an acknowledgement of how many of us are feeling stuck in our lives.
they are more sure of themselves. They are further along when it comes to their relationships, their finances, knowing what they want to do with their lives. This feeling of being behind is a really common one during this decade, during our 20s. It is the norm, not the exception. But I think despite that, it's also incredibly stressful and at times debilitating. when we, A, don't have open conversations about it, there isn't an acknowledgement of how many of us are feeling stuck in our lives.|||他们对自己更加笃定。他们在人际关系、财务状况以及明确自己想在生活中做什么方面，都比你走得更远。这种落后感在这个十年（也就是我们的二十多岁）里非常普遍。这是常态，而不是特例。但尽管如此，我认为它也带来了极大的压力，有时甚至会让人感到崩溃。当我们 A，没有就此展开公开对话时，大家并没有意识到我们当中有多少人正陷入生活的困境中。
And B, we constantly compare ourselves to the people who do have it all, feeling like everyone else is finding this whole life thing very easy whilst we're struggling. So I want to talk about it today. I want to talk about why it is that we find ourselves in this constant spiral, this constant self-doubt kind of cycle, no matter how much we do have, how much we have achieved. I think despite knowing that life is a journey, not a race, we still feel behind.
And B, we constantly compare ourselves to the people who do have it all, feeling like everyone else is finding this whole life thing very easy whilst we're struggling. So I want to talk about it today. I want to talk about why it is that we find ourselves in this constant spiral, this constant self-doubt kind of cycle, no matter how much we do have, how much we have achieved. I think despite knowing that life is a journey, not a race, we still feel behind.|||B，我们总是拿自己和那些拥有一切的人作比较，觉得其他人面对生活都轻而易举，而我们却在苦苦挣扎。所以我今天想聊聊这个。我想聊聊为什么无论我们拥有多少、取得多大的成就，我们总是陷入这种不断打转、不断自我怀疑的循环中。我认为，尽管我们知道人生是一场旅程，而不是一场赛跑，但我们仍然觉得自己落后了。
But I think the real question is, like, behind what? What is this invisible standard that we are all falling short of? What exactly are we comparing ourselves to and why does the success of other people and the accomplishments of other people sit so heavy on our minds and diminish our own sense of agency and our own progress. Well, that's really like the core of this discussion. This is such a common phenomena feeling behind in your 20s. And it's kind of ironic because if it is so common, how come we all experience it?
But I think the real question is, like, behind what? What is this invisible standard that we are all falling short of? What exactly are we comparing ourselves to and why does the success of other people and the accomplishments of other people sit so heavy on our minds and diminish our own sense of agency and our own progress. Well, that's really like the core of this discussion. This is such a common phenomena feeling behind in your 20s. And it's kind of ironic because if it is so common, how come we all experience it?|||但我认为真正的问题是，落后于什么？我们都在达不到的这个无形标准究竟是什么？我们到底在和什么作比较，为什么其他人的成功和成就会在我们的脑海里压得那么重，并削弱了我们自己的自主意识和成长进程？这其实就是本次讨论的核心。在二十多岁时感到落后是一个非常普遍的现象。这有点讽刺，因为既然它如此普遍，为什么我们所有人都会经历这种感觉？
Who are these like people who are not feeling behind? Why is it that they are seen as what is normal? Why is it the people who are ticking everything off their bucket list, achieving all the necessary milestones? Why are they the standard? I also want to share some of your experiences, the listeners. A lot of you have kindly written in to me on Instagram and said that you feel similar and have kind of articulated why you're struggling. We have stories of being 30 and single, never having been in a relationship, another person, who started their career again in their late 20s, people struggling with debt and decision making
Who are these like people who are not feeling behind? Why is it that they are seen as what is normal? Why is it the people who are ticking everything off their bucket list, achieving all the necessary milestones? Why are they the standard? I also want to share some of your experiences, the listeners. A lot of you have kindly written in to me on Instagram and said that you feel similar and have kind of articulated why you're struggling. We have stories of being 30 and single, never having been in a relationship, another person, who started their career again in their late 20s, people struggling with debt and decision making|||那些感觉没有落后的人到底是些什么人？为什么他们被视为正常的存在？为什么那些把愿望清单上的事情一一打勾、达成所有必要里程碑的人，会成为标准？我也想分享一些听众们的经历。你们很多人在 Instagram 上友好地给我写信，说你们也有同感，并阐述了你们为什么在挣扎。我们有三十岁单身、从未谈过恋爱的人的故事，还有人在二十多岁快结束时重新开始职业生涯，也有人为债务和决策而苦恼的人
and job choices and not feeling like you can see a way forward. And of course we're going to discuss why we feel that way, the psychology behind it, and what we can do about it. How we can kind of just, you know, to be frank, stop feeling so shit about our own lives and our own progress. How can we stop viewing our 20s as a race or a competition to get. to this like imaginary finish line and just enjoy the personal journey, enjoy the scenic route, enjoy what we want to get out of this decade. So there is obviously a lot to discuss alongside your very generous and vulnerable personal anecdotes. And my hope is that if you get one thing out of this episode today, it is that absolutely everybody is feeling behind or feeling lost or
and job choices and not feeling like you can see a way forward. And of course we're going to discuss why we feel that way, the psychology behind it, and what we can do about it. How we can kind of just, you know, to be frank, stop feeling so shit about our own lives and our own progress. How can we stop viewing our 20s as a race or a competition to get. to this like imaginary finish line and just enjoy the personal journey, enjoy the scenic route, enjoy what we want to get out of this decade. So there is obviously a lot to discuss alongside your very generous and vulnerable personal anecdotes. And my hope is that if you get one thing out of this episode today, it is that absolutely everybody is feeling behind or feeling lost or|||以及工作选择，觉得看不到前进的道路。当然，我们接下来会讨论我们为什么会有这种感觉，背后的心理学原因，以及我们可以做些什么。坦白讲，我们该如何停止对自己的生活和进展感到如此糟糕。我们该如何停止将二十多岁视为一场赛跑或竞争，去冲向那个虚构的终点线，而是去享受个人的旅程，享受沿途的风景，享受我们想从这个十年中获得的东西。因此，结合你们慷慨分享的脆弱个人轶事，显然有很多内容需要探讨。我希望，如果你能从今天的节目中收获哪怕一点，那就是绝对每个人都在某种程度上感到落后、迷茫或
feeling stuck in some capacity. Even the people that you look to and compare yourself to who seem so much further ahead than us, they genuinely are feeling this as well. Because I think that it isn't about what you do have. It isn't about what you have achieved. It's about our mindset and our mindset towards competition, towards success, towards uncertainty. So we have a lot to discuss. I'm going to stop rambling without further ado.
feeling stuck in some capacity. Even the people that you look to and compare yourself to who seem so much further ahead than us, they genuinely are feeling this as well. Because I think that it isn't about what you do have. It isn't about what you have achieved. It's about our mindset and our mindset towards competition, towards success, towards uncertainty. So we have a lot to discuss. I'm going to stop rambling without further ado.|||陷入困境。甚至连那些你仰望并与之比较、看起来比我们领先得多的人，其实也同样有这种感觉。因为我认为这与你拥有什么无关。这与你取得了什么成就无关。这关乎我们的心态，以及我们对竞争、成功和不确定性的心态。所以我们要讨论的话题很多。废话不多说，我这就停止唠叨。
do, let's get into feeling behind in our 20s. We have a lot of opportunities to feel behind in our 20s because we have a lot of opportunities not just for social comparison, but also for self-doubt. I think for the first two decades of our lives, for the first 18 years at least, all of us are very much in step with each other. You know, we're kind of all existing on an identical path. everybody who is our own age is doing the same things. We're going to school. We're trying to hit the same milestones of graduating. We're at the same classes. We have the same life problems.
do, let's get into feeling behind in our 20s. We have a lot of opportunities to feel behind in our 20s because we have a lot of opportunities not just for social comparison, but also for self-doubt. I think for the first two decades of our lives, for the first 18 years at least, all of us are very much in step with each other. You know, we're kind of all existing on an identical path. everybody who is our own age is doing the same things. We're going to school. We're trying to hit the same milestones of graduating. We're at the same classes. We have the same life problems.|||好啦，让我们来聊聊二十多岁的落后感。我们在二十多岁时有很多机会感到落后，因为我们不仅有很多机会进行社会比较，也有很多机会产生自我怀疑。我认为在我们生命的前二十年里，至少在前十八年里，我们所有人的步伐都非常一致。你知道的，我们基本上都生活在同一条轨道上。所有和我们同龄的人都在做同样的事情。我们在上学。我们试图达成相同的毕业里程碑。我们在同样的班级。我们面临同样的生活问题。
We are all working towards a common goal. Everything feels very much in line. There is limited opportunities for comparison when it comes to life progress. You know, you might be comparing yourself based on like looks or who's had their first kiss or, you know, silly things like that. But in terms of like where you're at in your life and the progress that you're making towards your goals, if you even have any when you're that young, that is all kind of very, very similar. And then we enter our 20s and suddenly it all splinters. Our life paths become very, very different, very unique. And that only is exacerbated the further along we get into our 20s and into this decade.
We are all working towards a common goal. Everything feels very much in line. There is limited opportunities for comparison when it comes to life progress. You know, you might be comparing yourself based on like looks or who's had their first kiss or, you6 know, silly things like that. But in terms of like where you're at in your life and the progress that you're making towards your goals, if you even have any when you're that young, that is all kind of very, very similar. And then we enter our 20s and suddenly it all splinters. Our life paths become very, very different, very unique. And that only is exacerbated the further along we get into our 20s and into this decade.|||我们都在为共同的目标努力。一切感觉都非常合拍。在生活进展方面，比较的机会是有限的。你知道的，你可能会根据外表、谁完成了初吻或者诸如此类傻里傻气的事情来做比较。但就你的人生处境以及你为实现目标所取得的进展而言（如果你在那么年轻的时候甚至有目标的话），这些都非常非常相似。然后我们进入了二十多岁，突然间这一切都支离破碎了。我们的人生轨迹变得非常非常不同，非常独特。随着我们在二十多岁以及这个十年中走得越远，这种现象就越发严重。
We're kind of no longer bustling alongside each other through mandatory schooling. We suddenly have freedom to choose and choose differently. And there are a lot of nuances in this. You know, one person wants to take a gap year. One person continues to work. Their high school job or their uni job to save up, another person speeds through their like four-year degree in three years and is like doing their master's by 23.
We're kind of no longer bustling alongside each other through mandatory schooling. We suddenly have freedom to choose and choose differently. And there are a lot of nuances in this. You know, one person wants to take a gap year. One person continues to work. Their high school job or their uni job to save up, another person speeds through their like four-year degree in three years and is like doing their master's by 23.|||我们不再一起匆匆忙忙地经历义务教育。我们突然有了选择的自由，并且可以做出不同的选择。这里面有很多细微的差别。你知道的，一个人想去间隔年。一个人继续做着高中或大学的兼职来存钱，另一个人则在三年内飞速读完四年的学位，23岁左右就开始读硕士了。
Somebody is going straight into a high-paying job after college. Somebody is having children, right? It's like everybody is suddenly living in a different timeline compared to the common timeline that we used to have. And I think that it's at that point when everything splinters, that it feels like a race suddenly begins. You know, it feels like we didn't realize we were at the starting line. We didn't realize that suddenly it was going to be a competition, but implicitly it
Somebody is going straight into a high-paying job after college. Somebody is having children, right? It's like everybody is suddenly living in a different timeline compared to the common timeline that we used to have. And I think that it's at that point when everything splinters, that it feels like a race suddenly begins. You know, it feels like we didn't realize we were at the starting line. We didn't realize that suddenly it was going to be a competition, but implicitly it|||有人大学毕业后直接进入高薪工作。有人开始生孩子，对吧？就像每个人突然都生活在与我们过去拥有的共同时间线不同的时间线上。我认为正是在一切分崩离析的那一刻，感觉就像一场赛跑突然开始了。你知道的，感觉就像我们没有意识到自己站在起跑线上。我们没有意识到这突然变成了一场竞争，但潜意识里它
feels that way. It's kind of like the race to become real adults. And in many ways, I think speaking to my friends, it feels like it's this race to enter our 30s or even like our mid 30s with a partner, with a successful and fulfilling career, with a really cushy savings account, with a bunch of friends and also with enough fun experiences to kind of prove that although we got here, we still enjoyed ourselves and enjoyed our lives along the way. and we become a lot more aware of the people who are doing those things and the people who are not, which might be us, the people who are falling short. I think the core reason we feel behind is obviously social comparison. Without the visibility of others and their life paths, we wouldn't have any reason to think that what we're doing is wrong.
feels that way. It's kind of like the race to become real adults. And in many ways, I think speaking to my friends, it feels like it's this race to enter our 30s or even like our mid 30s with a partner, with a successful and fulfilling career, with a really cushy savings account, with a bunch of friends and also with enough fun experiences to kind of prove that although we got here, we still enjoyed ourselves and enjoyed our lives along the way. and we become a lot more aware of the people who are doing those things and the people who are not, which might be us, the people who are falling short. I think the core reason we feel behind is obviously social comparison. Without the visibility of others and their life paths, we wouldn't have any reason to think that what we're doing is wrong.|||确实给人这种感觉。这有点像成为真正成年人的赛跑。在很多方面，我觉得和朋友交谈时，感觉就像是一场赛跑：要在进入30岁甚至30岁中期时，拥有一个伴侣、一份成功且充实的事业、一个相当优渥的银行账户、一帮朋友，同时还要有足够有趣的经历，来证明尽管我们走到了这里，但我们在沿途依然玩得开心、享受了生活。而且我们变得更加注意到那些正在做这些事情的人，以及那些没有做这些事情的人——这可能就是我们，那些有所欠缺的人。我认为我们感到落后的核心原因显然是社会比较。如果没有看到其他人及其人生轨迹，我们没有任何理由认为自己做错了什么。
We wouldn't have anybody to be behind because we would only be thinking about ourselves. we would only be conscious of our own progress and what felt good for us. But of course, we know that comparison is a very human disease. It's not even a disease, a human syndrome, a human trait. And sometimes it's just not possible to not have that kind of going on in the back of your mind as such a social tribal species. What's really fascinating to me, if not ironic, is when I asked all of you people, my beautiful listeners, whether you feel behind as someone in your 20s, 80% of you out of almost 5,000 votes, probably more,
We wouldn't have anybody to be behind because we would only be thinking about ourselves. we would only be conscious of our own progress and what felt good for us. But of course, we know that comparison is a very human disease. It's not even a disease, a human syndrome, a human trait. And sometimes it's just not possible to not have that kind of going on in the back of your mind as such a social tribal species. What's really fascinating to me, if not ironic, is when I asked all of you people, my beautiful listeners, whether you feel behind as someone in your 20s, 80% of you out of almost 5,000 votes, probably more,|||我们不会有任何人可以去落后，因为我们只会考虑自己。我们只会关注自己的进展以及什么对我们感觉良好。但当然，我们知道比较是人类的一种顽疾。甚至都不是疾病，是一种人类综合征，一种人类特质。有时候，作为这样一个具有社群属性的物种，你的脑海里不可能不去想这些。对我来说真正迷人（如果不算讽刺的话）的是，当我问你们所有人——我可爱的听众们，作为一个二十多岁的人，你们是否感到落后时，在近5000票（可能更多）中，有80%的人
because I checked that only after it had been up for like, I don't know, 14 hours. But 80% of you at 5,000 votes, so a significant sample size there, said yes, you are feeling behind. There is something in your life that you're not satisfied with, that you feel you should be further ahead or further along in regards to. that's compared to 20% of you who I assume feel really comfortable with where you're at, maybe you're secure, you're working on yourself, setting your own pace. You could also just be doing exceptionally well, which congratulations. But what I find fascinating about this is that feeling lost, feeling stuck, feeling unaccomplished, feeling behind is the norm.
because I checked that only after it had been up for like, I don't know, 14 hours. But 80% of you at 5,000 votes, so a significant sample size there, said yes, you are feeling behind. There is something in your life that you're not satisfied with, that you feel you should be further ahead or further along in regards to. that's compared to 20% of you who I assume feel really comfortable with where you're at, maybe you're secure, you're working on yourself, setting your own pace. You could also just be doing exceptionally well, which congratulations. But what I find fascinating about this is that feeling lost, feeling stuck, feeling unaccomplished, feeling behind is the norm.|||因为我查看时它已经发布了大概，我不知道，14个小时。但在5000票中，有80%的人——这是一个相当大的样本量——表示是的，你们感到了落后。你们生活中有某些事情不满意，觉得在这些方面自己本应该更超前或走得更远。相比之下，另外20%的人我猜对自己的现状感到非常舒适，也许你们很有安全感，在自我完善，按照自己的节奏前进。你们也可能只是做得非常出色，恭喜你们。但我对此感到着迷的是，感到迷茫、感到陷入困境、感到一事无成、感到落后才是常态。
It is not only the norm, it is the majority, it is the huge majority, 80%. You know, and I just think that it comes down to a lot of reasons, but because this generation is so much more competitive, but also yet again, available for comparison, right? Particularly through social media and LinkedIn and publicly available information, it's very easy to focus on everybody who has more than you and not the people who are just like you. The people who are doing really, really well for themselves, that 20%, maybe even that 10%, that 5%, they stand out. And so our attention immediately goes to them. Compared to the people who are doing life just like us in the same lane, that's not an interesting story. That's not going to capture our attention because we already know that narrative. We already know what that life looks like compared to the life of somebody that we want. We also can't ignore this implicit blueprint that society sets for
It is not only the norm, it is the majority, it is the huge majority, 80%. You know, and I just think that it comes down to a lot of reasons, but because this generation is so much more competitive, but also yet again, available for comparison, right? Particularly through social media and LinkedIn and publicly available information, it's very easy to focus on everybody who has more than you and not the people who are just like you. The people who are doing really, really well for themselves, that 20%, maybe even that 10%, that 5%, they stand out. And so our attention immediately goes to them. Compared to the people who are doing life just like us in the same lane, that's not an interesting story. That's not going to capture our attention because we already know that narrative. We already know what that life looks like compared to the life of somebody that we want. We also can't ignore this implicit blueprint that society sets for|||它不仅是常态，而且是大多数，是绝大多数，占了80%。你知道的，我只是觉得这归结于很多原因，其中之一就是这一代人竞争激烈得多，而且同样再次地，可供比较的信息也更多了，对吧？特别是在社交媒体、LinkedIn 以及公开信息的时代，我们很容易把注意力集中在所有比你拥有更多的人身上，而不是那些和你一样的人。那些过得非常非常好的人，那20%，甚至那10%，那5%，他们脱颖而出。于是我们的注意力立刻被他们吸引了。与那些和我们在同一轨道上过着普通生活的人相比，那并不是一个有趣的故事。那不会吸引我们的注意力，因为我们已经知道那种叙事了。与我们想要的生活相比，我们已经知道那样的人生是什么样的了。我们也不能忽视社会为我们设定的这种潜在蓝图
our life that even if we don't believe in, we are still influenced by. So when we think about like society's blueprint for us, there is kind of this unspoken timeline of events. You graduate, maybe you go on and get your degree or some qualification, you find your dream career, you get your job in that field, you make enough money to live independently, you find the love of your life, You get promoted, you buy a house, you get married, you have children, retirement, death. That's it. That's what the blueprint tells us. And it's a very restrictive idea of what constitutes a happy life. And it's also a very incomplete narrative, an incomplete blueprint.
our life that even if we don't believe in, we are still influenced by. So when we think about like society's blueprint for us, there is kind of this unspoken timeline of events. You graduate, maybe you go on and get your degree or some qualification, you find your dream career, you get your job in that field, you make enough money to live independently, you find the love of your life, You get promoted, you buy a house, you get married, you have children, retirement, death. That's it. That's what the blueprint tells us. And it's a very restrictive idea of what constitutes a happy life. And it's also a very incomplete narrative, an incomplete blueprint.|||即使我们不相信，也依然会受到它的影响。因此，当我们想到社会为我们绘制的蓝图时，存在着某种不成文的事件时间表。你毕业，也许你继续深造获得学位或某些资格证书，你找到梦想的职业，你在那个领域找到工作，你赚到足够的钱独立生活，你找到一生的挚爱，你升职，你买房，你结婚，你生子，退休，死亡。就这样。这就是蓝图告诉我们的。对于什么是幸福的生活，这是一个非常局限的观念。这也是一个非常不完整的叙事，一个不完整的蓝图。
Because it doesn't include the stories of people who, you know, completely uproot their lives at 30 or 50. The people who never get married or who never have kids. the people who take a few years off between graduation and full-time work to explore. The people who never find their dream job. The people who, you know, these kind of milestones just aren't going to happen in the same way for them. Those stories, the ones that I've just kind of given a few examples of, they're not the ones we hear about. And so we don't think of them or include them in our own interpretation of how our lives should be going. how our lives should be progressing.
Because it doesn't include the stories of people who, you know, completely uproot their lives at 30 or 50. The people who never get married or who never have kids. the people who take a few years off between graduation and full-time work to explore. The people who never find their dream job. The people who, you know, these kind of milestones just aren't going to happen in the same way for them. Those stories, the ones that I've just kind of given a few examples of, they're not the ones we hear about. And so we don't think of them or include them in our own interpretation of how our lives should be going. how our lives should be progressing.|||因为它不包括那些在30岁或50岁时彻底改变生活轨迹的人的故事。那些从未结婚或从未要孩子的人。那些在毕业和全职工作之间花几年时间去探索的人。那些从未找到梦想工作的人。那些你知道的，这些里程碑对他们来说不会以同样方式发生的人。这些故事——我刚刚举了几个例子的那些——并不是我们经常听到的。因此，在我们对自己的人生应该如何发展、人生应该如何进展的解读中，我们不会想到它们，也不会将它们包含在内。
When it comes to feeling behind, I believe that there are three major areas where we experience this the most. That is our careers, our relationships, and our finances. Not only are these three of the most formative elements of our 20s, the things that I think we spend a lot of time worrying about, but in some ways they're also quite visible, right? We don't feel behind in terms of our health. We don't feel behind in terms of aging. We don't feel behind in terms of our personal development.
When it comes to feeling behind, I believe that there are three major areas where we experience this the most. That is our careers, our relationships, and our finances. Not only are these three of the most formative elements of our 20s, the things that I think we spend a lot of time worrying about, but in some ways they're also quite visible, right? We don't feel behind in terms of our health. We don't feel behind in terms of aging. We don't feel behind in terms of our personal development.|||谈到落后感，我认为我们在三个主要领域体验得最深。那就是我们的职业、人际关系和财务状况。这不仅是我们二十多岁时最具决定性的三个要素，也是我认为我们花大量时间去担忧的事情，而且在某种程度上它们也是相当显而易见的，对吧？我们不会在健康方面感到落后。我们在衰老方面不会感到落后。我们在个人发展方面不会感到落后。
We feel behind based on things that we think that other people can see. So I think let's start with the biggest one that I heard from you all, which is career goals. I think this is the most common of the three because it feels like something that we really need to grow. And so the time we spend on it and the results feel like an investment. They feel very precious. Like when it comes to relationships, you could meet like the love of your life tomorrow and complete that part of your story. But your career takes a little bit longer to establish.
We feel behind based on things that we think that other people can see. So I think let's start with the biggest one that I heard from you all, which is career goals. I think this is the most common of the three because it feels like something that we really need to grow. And so the time we spend on it and the results feel like an investment. They feel very precious. Like when it comes to relationships, you could meet like the love of your life tomorrow and complete that part of your story. But your career takes a little bit longer to establish.|||我们感到落后是基于那些我们认为别人能看到的方面。所以我想，让我们从你们所有人反馈最多的最大痛点开始，那就是职业目标。我认为这是这三者中最普遍的一个，因为它感觉像是我们真正需要成长的事情。因此，我们花在上面的时间和结果感觉就像是一项投资。它们感觉非常珍贵。就像在人际关系方面，你可能明天就会遇到你一生的挚爱，从而完成你故事的那一部分。但你的职业生涯需要更长的时间来建立。
And it feels very intentional. So we put a lot of pressure on ourselves to get it right the first time around. To get it right, straight out the gate because we don't want to spend like five years doing something that we think we love or we think we'll be fulfilling and then, you know, we hit 30 and it's like a waste of our time. That's how we interpret it. We have to start again. You know, we want to feel like we're doing things productively. We want to feel like we're making a contribution to our future. And so I think that fear of not getting it right the first time, that fear of not knowing of uncertainty, it really
And it feels very intentional. So we put a lot of pressure on ourselves to get it right the first time around. To get it right, straight out the gate because we don't want to spend like five years doing something that we think we love or we think we'll be fulfilling and then, you know, we hit 30 and it's like a waste of our time. That's how we interpret it. We have to start again. You know, we want to feel like we're doing things productively. We want to feel like we're making a contribution to our future. And so I think that fear of not getting it right the first time, that fear of not knowing of uncertainty, it really|||而且这感觉非常有目的性。所以我们给自己施加了很大的压力，要求自己第一次就把它做好。一上手就要做对，因为我们不想花个五年时间去做一件我们以为自己喜欢或以为会有成就感的事情，然后，你知道的，等到了30岁，就好像浪费了我们的时间。我们就是这么解读的。我们不得不重新开始。你知道的，我们希望感觉自己做事富有成效。我们希望感觉自己正在为我们的未来做出贡献。所以我觉得这种害怕第一次做不对的恐惧，这种对未知、对不确定性的恐惧，真的
keeps us in places, in industries, in careers, in fields, in jobs that we don't fully love because we don't want to sacrifice the security of experience and have to start again. We also don't want to feel like a failure, right? We don't want people to, you know, catch up with us and ask us, how's work going and be like, yeah, it's all right. It's fine, as if we should be doing more, as if we're wasting our time or wasting our lives, doing something that we don't fully love and not even doing it at a high level compared to other people. So I asked you guys about this and I wanted to hear about your experience.
keeps us in places, in industries, in careers, in fields, in jobs that we don't fully love because we don't want to sacrifice the security of experience and have to start again. We also don't want to feel like a failure, right? We don't want people to, you know, catch up with us and ask us, how's work going and be like, yeah, it's all right. It's fine, as if we should be doing more, as if we're wasting our time or wasting our lives, doing something that we don't fully love and not even doing it at a high level compared to other people. So I asked you guys about this and I wanted to hear about your experience.|||把我们留在了那些我们并不完全热爱的行业、职业、领域和工作岗位上，因为我们不想牺牲经验带来的安全感而重新开始。我们也不想觉得自己是个失败者，对吧？我们不希望别人，你知道的，赶上我们然后问我们，工作怎么样啊，然后回答说，嗯，还行。挺好的，就好像我们本该做得更多，就好像我们在浪费时间或浪费生命，在做一件我们并不完全热爱的事情，而且与其他人相比，甚至没有达到很高的水平。所以我向你们询问了这件事，并想听听你们的经历。
Why do you feel behind in your career? And here's what some of you had to say. This one I absolutely love. I'm coming up on one year post-uny this May and I feel some sadness about it because I thought that I'd be further along by now. And the one-year marker is just another reminder that I'm not. After post-gride, it took me a while to find a job. That is so common, trust me. But when I did, it sounded.
Why do you feel behind in your career? And here's what some of you had to say. This one I absolutely love. I'm coming up on one year post-uny this May and I feel some sadness about it because I thought that I'd be further along by now. And the one-year marker is just another reminder that I'm not. After post-gride, it took me a while to find a job. That is so common, trust me. But when I did, it sounded.|||为什么你在职业生涯中会感到落后？以下是其中一些听众的留言。我非常喜欢这一条。今年五月份我就大学毕业满一年了，对此我感到有些难过，因为我本以为自己现在应该走得更远了。而这一周年的纪念日只是又一次提醒我，我并没有。毕业后，我花了一段时间才找到工作。相信我，这太普遍了。但当我找到工作时，听起来
great on paper working in a professional newsroom at the number one channel in the third biggest city in the US. Wow, impressive. After a few months of giving it a shot, I made the decision to leave because my intuition was telling me I had to go and I don't regret it. And then my dad fell sick, better now. Oh, thank goodness. That's always good to hear. Fast forward to now, I feel like I'm back to square one of the job search process. And I'm debating if I should go back to school and pursue an entirely different field outside of media. I feel shame about it even though I think it is very normal to go through at this age. Thank you so much for sharing. I feel like a lot of people can relate to that. I'm also really glad that your dad is doing better. That's really good news. I want to pick up on one
great on paper working in a professional newsroom at the number one channel in the third biggest city in the US. Wow, impressive. After a few months of giving it a shot, I made the decision to leave because my intuition was telling me I had to go and I don't regret it. And then my dad fell sick, better now. Oh, thank goodness. That's always good to hear. Fast forward to now, I feel like I'm back to square one of the job search process. And I'm debating if I should go back to school and pursue an entirely different field outside of media. I feel shame about it even though I think it is very normal to go through at this age. Thank you so much for sharing. I feel like a lot of people can relate to that. I'm also really glad that your dad is doing better. That's really good news. I want to pick up on one|||纸面上听起来棒极了，在美国第三大城市的头号频道的一个专业新闻编辑室工作。哇，令人印象深刻。尝试了几个月后，我做出了离开的决定，因为我的直觉告诉我必须走，我并不后悔。然后我爸爸生病了，现在好些了。哦，谢天谢地。听到这个总是让人高兴。快进到现在，我觉得自己又回到了求职过程的原点。我正在纠结是否应该重返校园，去追求一个完全脱离传媒领域的全新方向。我为此感到羞愧，尽管我认为在这个年龄经历这些非常正常。非常感谢你的分享。我觉得很多人都能感同身受。我也很高兴你父亲的身体好转了。这真是个好消息。我想挑出其中
thing that this person said and it was around the feeling of shame. I think that shame element, that shame factor is something that we really need to focus on because starting again or acknowledging that we aren't necessarily where we want to be or imagined that we would be makes us feel in some way like we have failed, that we weren't up for it, that we weren't capable, that we made a huge mistake. And shame has a lot of psychological origins, but one of the biggest ones is feeling like we have not lived up to the highest standards that we have set ourselves or our expectations. and therefore we kind of deserve to feel bad, we deserve some kind of negative emotional consequence as kind of like retribution for failing ourselves.
thing that this person said and it was around the feeling of shame. I think that shame element, that shame factor is something that we really need to focus on because starting again or acknowledging that we aren't necessarily where we want to be or imagined that we would be makes us feel in some way like we have failed, that we weren't up for it, that we weren't capable, that we made a huge mistake. And shame has a lot of psychological origins, but one of the biggest ones is feeling like we have not lived up to the highest standards that we have set ourselves or our expectations. and therefore we kind of deserve to feel bad, we deserve some kind of negative emotional consequence as kind of like retribution for failing ourselves.|||一个人说过的话，那就是关于羞耻感。我认为羞耻感的这个要素，这个羞耻因素，是我们真正需要关注的，因为重新开始或者承认我们不一定处在自己想要的位置，或者没有达到想象中的位置，在某种程度上让我们觉得自己失败了，觉得我们力不从心，觉得我们没有能力，觉得我们犯了大错。羞耻感有很多心理根源，但其中最大的根源之一，就是觉得自己没有达到自己为自己设定的最高标准或期望。因此我们觉得自己活该感觉糟糕，我们应该承受某种负面情绪后果，就像是对辜负了自己的惩罚一样。
It's also really frequently linked in academic research to a sense of inadequacy, which if you are a long-time listener, you know is also related to being an overachiever, being a perfectionist, or being somebody who is quite anxious. Shame is a really common experience for the people that I've spoken. spoken to who, for example, have maybe taken a little bit longer to finish university, who have made a career change, who have had to spend a lot more time in those junior roles all over again. The other big group of people who experience this are those of us who have been fired or laid off, because we don't typically think about those situations when we're planning our dream life, right?
It's also really frequently linked in academic research to a sense of inadequacy, which if you are a long-time listener, you know is also related to being an overachiever, being a perfectionist, or being somebody who is quite anxious. Shame is a really common experience for the people that I've spoken. spoken to who, for example, have maybe taken a little bit longer to finish university, who have made a career change, who have had to spend a lot more time in those junior roles all over again. The other big group of people who experience this are those of us who have been fired or laid off, because we don't typically think about those situations when we're planning our dream life, right?|||在学术研究中，它也经常与无能感联系在一起，如果你是老听众，你就知道这也与好胜心强、完美主义或相当焦虑的人有关。对于我交谈过的人来说，羞耻感是一种非常普遍的经历。比如那些花更长时间才读完大学的人，那些经历过转行的人，那些不得不再次在初级岗位上花更多时间的人。经历这种感觉的另一个庞大群体是那些被解雇或裁员的人，因为我们在规划梦想生活时，通常不会考虑这些情况，对吧？
I've had a few friends who have gone through this recently, and it's really, really shitty. It's a really frustrating situation. And I think it's because in those situations, even though it's out of our control, we become very acutely aware of how our expectation for the future and where we would be at now and our reality is not lining up. And on some more social level, we focus on what we believe other people might assume about us because of that experience, because of being laid off, but also how everybody else is continuing to save up money,
I've had a few friends who have gone through this recently, and it's really, really shitty. It's a really frustrating situation. And I think it's because in those situations, even though it's out of our control, we become very acutely aware of how our expectation for the future and where we would be at now and our reality is not lining up. And on some more social level, we focus on what we believe other people might assume about us because of that experience, because of being laid off, but also how everybody else is continuing to save up money,|||我最近有几个朋友经历了这种情况，这感觉真的非常非常糟糕。这是一个非常令人沮丧的局面。我认为这是因为在这种情况下，尽管这超出了我们的控制，但我们变得非常敏锐地意识到，我们对未来的期望、我们现在本该处的位置与我们的现实是如何不符的。而在更广泛的社会层面，我们会关注我们认为别人会因为这段经历、因为被裁员而对我们产生怎样的看法，同时也会关注其他人是如何继续存钱的、
is continuing to progress, is continuing to have those years of experience on their resume, and our efforts are doing that have been cut short. I think it's really important to remember that your career, whilst it is important, is not the sole basis of your identity or your worth. There is so much beyond what you do for a job that makes you interesting and makes you accomplished and makes you a good person.
is continuing to progress, is continuing to have those years of experience on their resume, and our efforts are doing that have been cut short. I think it's really important to remember that your career, whilst it is important, is not the sole basis of your identity or your worth. There is so much beyond what you do for a job that makes you interesting and makes you accomplished and makes you a good person.|||是如何继续取得进步的、是如何在简历上继续积累那些年经验的，而我们朝这个方向的努力却中断了。我认为非常重要的一点是要记住，你的职业虽然重要，但它并不是你身份或价值的唯一基础。除了你从事的工作之外，还有太多其他事情能让你变得有趣、让你取得成就、让你成为一个优秀的人。
Just because it's taking a little bit longer for you to be where you would like to be, doesn't mean that you're not picking up valuable things along the way. Okay, let's hear from somebody else who I think really, really demonstrates this point. I went to uni at 25 and people were so supportive. I'd never done higher education. I became a hairdresser at 16 and went traveling for a couple of years. so this was huge for me. However, since finishing uni, I've stepped back into hospitality full time. And I feel like I should be doing more, knowing my direction, have more to show for it. Don't get me wrong.
Just because it's taking a little bit longer for you to be where you would like to be, doesn't mean that you're not picking up valuable things along the way. Okay, let's hear from somebody else who I think really, really demonstrates this point. I went to uni at 25 and people were so supportive. I'd never done higher education. I became a hairdresser at 16 and went traveling for a couple of years. so this was huge for me. However, since finishing uni, I've stepped back into hospitality full time. And I feel like I should be doing more, knowing my direction, have more to show for it. Don't get me wrong.|||仅仅因为你达到自己想去的地方需要花更长一点的时间，并不意味着你在沿途没有收获有价值的东西。好的，让我们听听另一个人的经历，我觉得这个人非常非常完美地证明了这一点。我25岁才上大学，大家非常支持我。我从未接受过高等教育。我16岁就成了一名美发师，还去旅行了几年。所以这对意义重大。然而，自从大学毕业后，我又全职回到了酒店行业。我觉得我应该做更多的事情，明确自己的方向，并取得更多成果。别误会我。
I love my job and I progressed position wise. I've also recently lost my savings due to a savage house situation. I just see everyone at 27 having so much more financially, materialistically, relationship wise, and knowing their direction in life. Maybe this is a perception, and also massively from social media's perspective. We've also been single for nine years now, so in all departments, feeling behind. See, I think this is also the hard thing, which is congratulations, like you went to uni,
I love my job and I progressed position wise. I've also recently lost my savings due to a savage house situation. I just see everyone at 27 having so much more financially, materialistically, relationship wise, and knowing their direction in life. Maybe this is a perception, and also massively from social media's perspective. We've also been single for nine years now, so in all departments, feeling behind. See, I think this is also the hard thing, which is congratulations, like you went to uni,|||我热爱我的工作，并且在职位上也有所晋升。而且我最近因为糟糕的住房状况而失去了积蓄。我看到27岁的每个人在财务、物质、人际关系上都拥有那么多，并且清楚自己的人生方向。也许这是一种错觉，很大程度上也源于社交媒体的视角。而且我已经单身九年了，所以在各个方面都觉得落后。你看，我认为这也是困难所在，那就是恭喜你，比如你上了大学，
you went and got like further education. Everyone says that that is like the easiest way to advance and move forward in your career and in your life. But a lot of us are not finding that, right? Like a lot of us have degrees that we don't use and debt that kind of just weighs very heavily on our mind and restricts the other opportunities that we could have in our life that we could unlock if we didn't have to worry about paying back alone or whatnot.
you went and got like further education. Everyone says that that is like the easiest way to advance and move forward in your career and in your life. But a lot of us are not finding that, right? Like a lot of us have degrees that we don't use and debt that kind of just weighs very heavily on our mind and restricts the other opportunities that we could have in our life that we could unlock if we didn't have to worry about paying back alone or whatnot.|||你去接受了高等教育。每个人都说那是提升和推进你职业生涯和生活最简单的方式。但我们中的很多人并没有切身体会到这一点，对吧？比如我们很多人拿着不用不上的学位，背负着沉重压在心头的债务，这些债务限制了我们在生活中本来可以拥有的其他机会——如果我们不用担心偿还贷款之类的事情的话，我们本可以解锁这些机会。
Here's another perspective on this that I really liked. I have everything that I've ever wanted in my life right now. I have a college degree, wonderful partner. I live in a big city, wonderful friends, fulfilling job, etc. But I constantly feel like I'm behind or studying, myself up for failure with my finances. I have 30k in student loan debt in the United States, stagnant 6K in credit card debt and I'm renting an apartment. When I talk with friends who don't have these situations with their finances, I see that they're able to save for a house, go on fun, exotic
Here's another perspective on this that I really liked. I have everything that I've ever wanted in my life right now. I have a college degree, wonderful partner. I live in a big city, wonderful friends, fulfilling job, etc. But I constantly feel like I'm behind or studying, myself up for failure with my finances. I have 30k in student loan debt in the United States, stagnant 6K in credit card debt and I'm renting an apartment. When I talk with friends who don't have these situations with their finances, I see that they're able to save for a house, go on fun, exotic|||关于这一点，有另一个视角我非常喜欢。我目前拥有我生活中一直想要的一切。我有大学学历，棒极了的伴侣。我住在大大城市里，有着绝佳的朋友、充实的工作等等。但我不断地觉得自己在财务上落后了，或者是在自寻死路。我在美国有三万美元的学生贷款债务，还有停滞不前的六千美元信用卡债务，而且我还租着公寓。当我与那些没有这些财务状况的朋友交谈时，我看到他们能够存钱买房、去有趣迷人的地方
trips, buy new cars, etc. I know I shouldn't compare, but it's so hard not to when these are people that I surround myself with. They are my community and I love them so deeply, but I think that I feel like I can't be transparent with how behind I feel from them. Honestly, money is a huge thing separate to career. You could have your absolute dream job, which by the sounds of it this person does, they love what they're doing, and still be struggling financially and feeling behind because of it. I think that the older you get, the more you realize that as unfortunate as it is, money kind of does make the world go around these days. And it's really hard to ignore that fact when you see people who do have more seemingly enjoying
trips, buy new cars, etc. I know I shouldn't compare, but it's so hard not to when these are people that I surround myself with. They are my community and I love them so deeply, but I think that I feel like I can't be transparent with how behind I feel from them. Honestly, money is a huge thing separate to career. You could have your absolute dream job, which by the sounds of it this person does, they love what they're doing, and still be struggling financially and feeling behind because of it. I think that the older you get, the more you realize that as unfortunate as it is, money kind of does make the world go around these days. And it's really hard to ignore that fact when you see people who do have more seemingly enjoying|||旅行、买新车等等。我知道我不应该攀比，但当这些人就围绕在我身边时，真的很难不去做比较。他们是我的社群，我深深地爱着他们，但我觉得我无法向他们坦白我感到的那种落后于他们的心情。老实说，金钱是一个独立于职业的巨大问题。你可能拥有绝对梦想的工作（听起来这个人确实拥有，他们热爱自己做的事），但仍然在财务上苦苦挣扎，并因此感到落后。我认为人越老，就越会意识到，尽管很不幸，如今金钱确实能让世界运转。当你看到那些确实拥有更多财富的人似乎在享受着
their experiences and accumulating possessions and accumulating memories at a faster rate than we are. And not having to make the sacrifices that we do, it can leave us with a sense that we will always be behind. We didn't get kind of like the early start that they did to save, to invest, to set ourselves up for long term, financial independence. We're never going to have it as good as these other people did. It really manifests in, I think, some significant financial anxiety. And I also think financial cynicism, where we kind of think, like, why am I even trying? Why am I even bothering to save when these people already got a head start?
their experiences and accumulating possessions and accumulating memories at a faster rate than we are. And not having to make the sacrifices that we do, it can leave us with a sense that we will always be behind. We didn't get kind of like the early start that they did to save, to invest, to set ourselves up for long term, financial independence. We're never going to have it as good as these other people did. It really manifests in, I think, some significant financial anxiety. And I also think financial cynicism, where we kind of think, like, why am I even trying? Why am I even bothering to save when these people already got a head start?|||他们的经历，并以比我们更快的速度积累财富和回忆时，你很难忽视这个事实。而且他们不必像我们那样做出牺牲，这会让我们产生一种感觉：我们将永远落后。我们没有像他们那样尽早开始储蓄、投资、为长期的财务独立做好准备。我们永远不会像其他人那样过得那么好。我认为这确实表现为一些显著的财务焦虑。我也认为这表现为一种财务愤世嫉俗，我们会觉得，为什么我还要努力？当这些人已经抢占先机时，我为什么还要费劲去存钱呢？
When will I ever be able to afford the life I want? And if I can't afford the life I want, why not just enjoy the most. now and spend willy-nilly and spend money frivolously because it's not like I can use this for a house. It's not like I can use this for a down payment for anything that's going to bring me like long-term stability because the economy hasn't been set up for me. The economy hasn't been set up for, you know, younger people who are trying to assert themselves and trying to find stability and trying to buy a home or trying to at least have the capacity to like pay their bills. Beyond just fulfilling our most basic needs, I also want to talk about that feeling that if we are behind in finances, if we are behind in savings, we are behind in our capacity, our future capacity to enjoy our lives.
When will I ever be able to afford the life I want? And if I can't afford the life I want, why not just enjoy the most. now and spend willy-nilly and spend money frivolously because it's not like I can use this for a house. It's not like I can use this for a down payment for anything that's going to bring me like long-term stability because the economy hasn't been set up for me. The economy hasn't been set up for, you know, younger people who are trying to assert themselves and trying to find stability and trying to buy a home or trying to at least have the capacity to like pay their bills. Beyond just fulfilling our most basic needs, I also want to talk about that feeling that if we are behind in finances, if we are behind in savings, we are behind in our capacity, our future capacity to enjoy our lives.|||我什么时候才能负担得起我想要的生活？如果我负担不起我想要的生活，为什么不尽情享受当下，随心所欲地花钱、挥霍无度呢，反正我也不能用这些钱去买房。我也不能用这些钱作为能给我带来长期稳定之类东西的首付，因为现在的经济环境根本不是为我们设立的。经济环境没有为那些——你知道的——试图证明自己、试图寻找稳定、试图买房或者至少有能力支付账单的年轻人做好准备。除了满足我们最基本的需求之外，我还想谈谈那种感觉：如果在财务上落后了，如果在存款上落后了，我们在享受生活的能力、未来的能力方面也就落后了。
I don't think that this fear is about what somebody else has. It's not about what they have that we don't. It's about an even deeper and sometimes unconscious worry that because we don't are not achieving that kind of level of, financial independence or savings or whatever, we are destined to lead an unfulfilling life. If we acknowledge that money is a really pertinent, important resource for unlocking a certain lifestyle, it is this fear that if we don't have that money, we are going to have to live with regret of the opportunities, of the travel plans, of the material possessions that we couldn't afford and that that regret is going to become more pronounced by seeing the people who do have it
I don't think that this fear is about what somebody else has. It's not about what they have that we don't. It's about an even deeper and sometimes unconscious worry that because we don't are not achieving that kind of level of, financial independence or savings or whatever, we are destined to lead an unfulfilling life. If we acknowledge that money is a really pertinent, important resource for unlocking a certain lifestyle, it is this fear that if we don't have that money, we are going to have to live with regret of the opportunities, of the travel plans, of the material possessions that we couldn't afford and that that regret is going to become more pronounced by seeing the people who do have it|||我不认为这种恐惧是关于别人拥有什么。这无关他们拥有而我们没有的东西。这关乎一种更深层、有时甚至是无意识的担忧：因为我们没有达到那种财务独立或存款等水平，我们注定要过一种不充实的生活。如果我们承认金钱是开启某种生活方式真正切题、重要的资源，那么正是这种恐惧在作祟：如果我们没有那些钱，我们就不得不带着遗憾生活，遗憾那些我们负担不起的机会、旅行计划、物质财富，而这种遗憾会因为看到那些确实拥有这些东西的人而变得更加明显。
better, who were able to buy those things. Money unlocks opportunity and it unlocks a life that we want. I'm not going to go into a lecture around like money doesn't buy you happiness. Like you can be the richest person in the world and still never have enough because I just think that's not helpful. But I will say that in our 20s, we tend to think that the money we are making now is the money that we will be making. forever. We don't often consider things like bonuses, promotions, changing jobs, sudden windfalls. So yes, it's important to be conscious of your finances and what you can spend, but you do never really know when things will change for you. Okay, I think that we are going to take a short break because the moment I start giving financial advice is the moment that I need to get back into my own lane.
better, who were able to buy those things. Money unlocks opportunity and it unlocks a life that we want. I'm not going to go into a lecture around like money doesn't buy you happiness. Like you can be the richest person in the world and still never have enough because I just think that's not helpful. But I will say that in our 20s, we tend to think that the money we are making now is the money that we will be making. forever. We don't often consider things like bonuses, promotions, changing jobs, sudden windfalls. So yes, it's important to be conscious of your finances and what you can spend, but you do never really know when things will change for you. Okay, I think that we are going to take a short break because the moment I start giving financial advice is the moment that I need to get back into my own lane.|||那些能够买得起这些东西的人。金钱开启了机遇，也开启了我们想要的生活。我不会长篇大论地讲什么“金钱买不到幸福”。比如你可以是世界上最富有的人却依然觉得不够，因为我觉得这种大道理没什么用。但我想说的是，在二十多岁时，我们往往会认为我们现在赚的钱就是我们以后会永远赚的钱。我们经常不考虑诸如奖金、晋升、跳槽、突然飞来横财之类的事情。所以，是的，对自己的财务状况和消费能力保持清醒的认识很重要，但你永远不知道事情什么时候会为你发生改变。好吧，我想我们要进行短暂的休息，因为当我开始提供财务建议的那一刻，就是我需要回到自己轨道上的时候。
So we are going to pause for a second. And when we come back, we're going to discuss especially, specifically, particularly why we feel behind in our relationships and then also what we can do about this experience. So stay with us. We'll be back in just a second. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
So we are going to pause for a second. And when we come back, we're going to discuss especially, specifically, particularly why we feel behind in our relationships and then also what we can do about this experience. So stay with us. We'll be back in just a second. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.|||所以我们要暂停一下。当我们回来时，我们将专门、具体、特别地讨论为什么我们在人际关系中感到落后，以及我们能对这种经历做些什么。所以请不要走开。我们马上回来。2%. 这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of men. mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of men. mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.|||在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析男子气概、心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养恢复力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾坚信种子油本身具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?|||让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即 TWO percent，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上拍打小基姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小基姆到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.|||好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会在这里挑选事件，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的快克毒品。需要明确的是，84年对我很重大，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?|||我随时可以聊聊快克，但只是让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们第二集讨论快克了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿的主线了。我们现在桌面上还有艾滋病。谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're|||是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师 Kear Games。为了迎接心理健康意识月，我将结合自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，并与众多不可思议的嘉宾展开对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们
in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.|||在追求某样东西时，我们过度沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总在盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.|||史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，是因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要吗？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两个不同级别的信任。我希望你只是真正地做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search, learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023,
Join me, Kear Games, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search, learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023,|||加入我 Kear Games，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你的免费 iHeartRadio App。搜索“learn the hard way”并立即收听。2023年，
former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistency in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistency in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.|||前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了她言辞中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场历时数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾两度篡改这个特定的测试以出售，对吗？我篡改过测试。大批互联网侦探花了一番功夫才破获此案。我想让人们看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. this is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. this is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.|||阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马林奇尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. We put a pretty significant premium on romantic love. in our 20s. I think it is one of our biggest sources of stress, of anxiety, a very huge focus of our everyday thoughts because it's very hard to feel complete in a society that prioritizes the idea
女士们先生们，美利哥帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因涉嫌欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。在二十多岁时，我们对浪漫爱情有着非常高的期望。我认为这是我们最大的压力和焦虑来源之一，是我们日常想法中的一个巨大焦点，因为在一个优先考虑
of love and relationships and happily ever after above everything else. Our society harbors a lot of single stigma, but not everyone is going to find their person in their 20s or their 30s. or even their 40s. For some people, it really does take their whole lives, and it doesn't mean that you are behind. Like, without love, your life is empty. Without a partner, everything is glass half full. I don't think that we should buy into this misconception as well,
爱情、关系以及从此过上幸福生活高于一切的社会里，很难感到自己是完整的。我们的社会对单身存在很多污名，但并不是每个人都能在二十多岁、三十多岁甚至四十多岁时找到自己的另一半。对某些人来说，这确实需要他们的一生，但这并不意味着你落后了。好像没有了爱，你的生活就是空虚的。没有伴侣，一切都显得悲观消极。我认为我们不应该轻信这种误解，
that a relationship is something that we need to tick off our to do list. It's not a goal. It's not a milestone. It's something that we naturally fall into. And if it works, that's amazing. That is such great news. But if it doesn't, that's all right. There is a whole portion of society who has found deep joy and fulfillment without a partner
即恋爱是我们待办事项清单上需要勾掉的一项任务。它不是一个目标。它不是一个里程碑。它是我们自然而然陷入的一种状态。如果它奏效了，那太棒了。这真是个好消息。但如果没有，也没关系。社会上有一大群人在没有伴侣的情况下找到了深层的快乐和成就感，
and who, you know, experience insane, transformative growth at the end of a relationship that completely pushes them into a new chapter in their life. I also think that the fear of being alone and therefore behind other people in our lives who have these serious long-term relationships who are, getting engaged, who are getting married, having children, sometimes that fear of not being where these people are at and falling quote unquote behind them keeps us in relationships with the people who aren't right for you because at least you meet society's requirement for your 20s, for partnership, for finding love. It's a really hard feeling to not have that and it's possibly an
而且他们（你知道的）在一段关系的终点经历了疯狂的、变革性的成长，这完全将他们推向了他们人生的新篇章。我也认为，害怕孤独以及因此害怕落后于我们生活中那些有着严肃长期关系、正在订婚、结婚、生孩子的人，有时这种害怕自己赶不上这些人并被“抛在后面”的恐惧，会让我们继续和那些不适合你的人在一起，因为至少你满足了社会对你二十多岁时关于伴侣关系、寻找真爱的要求。没有这种经历是一种非常难受的感觉，而从来没有体验过爱，或者根本不知道大肆宣扬的到底是什么，这种感觉可能
even worse feeling to never have experienced love or really know what all the hype is about. who not have even had your first kiss, your first girlfriend, your first boyfriend, your first partner. So this was an amazing DM I received on this very kind of feeling that I had to share. I personally feel most behind in the area of romantic relationships. I am 29 and I've never been in a relationship, not even close. Everyone has assured me that there's no timeline. It will happen when you're not looking slash least expect it, which I think is easy for them to say, from the comforts of their relationships and marriages. I have worked hard throughout my 20s to grow in my self-love and self-worth.
甚至更糟，甚至连你的初吻、第一个女朋友、第一个男朋友、第一个伴侣都没有过。所以，我收到了关于这种特定感受的一条非常棒的私信，我不得不分享一下。我个人感觉在恋爱关系方面落后最多。我29岁了，从来没有谈过恋爱，甚至连边都没沾过。每个人都向来向我保证，人生没有时间表。当你没有寻找或最不期待的时候，它就会发生，我认为他们坐在伴侣关系和婚姻的舒适区里，说这话倒是挺容易的。在整个二十多岁期间，我一直在努力提升自己的自爱和自我价值。
That's amazing. We love to hear it. And to not let the feeling of being so behind affect me as much as it used to. But I'd be lying to say it wasn't still hard some days. It feels like it will never happen. And if it does, I worry I won't be able to enjoy a new first relationship the same way that others have because of this impending rushed feeling, especially. when it comes to deciding if I would want kids or not. That is really, really rough.
这太棒了。我们很乐意听到这些。并且努力不让这种落后的感觉像过去那样影响我。但我如果说某些日子里这依然很难熬，那我就是在撒谎。感觉它永远不会发生。如果它真的发生了，我担心自己会因为这种即将到来的仓促感而无法像其他人那样好好享受一段全新的初恋，尤其是当涉及到决定我是否想要孩子的时候。这真的，真的很艰难。
And I think that comment about people saying things which they think are helping when they aren't is so spot on. Honestly, it's a big reminder to those of us who are in relationships that we think our words are comforting, but we don't remember how rough it is being single in our 20s or even in our 30s or being single at all sometimes. I also think that the reason it can be especially difficult being single, the lady you get into this decade, is because the achievements and milestones of a single person aren't as celebrated as those in a relationship. Think about what the biggest celebration in adulthood kind of is.
我认为关于人们说那些他们认为有帮助但实际上并没有的话的评论真是太中的要害了。说实话，这对我们这些身处恋爱关系中的人是一个巨大的提醒，我们以为自己的话是在安慰人，但我们却不记得在二十多岁甚至三十多岁时单身是有多艰难，或者有时单身本身就有多艰难。我也认为，随着你进入这个十年，单身之所以会特别困难，是因为单身人士的成就和庆祝不如恋爱中的人那样受人瞩目。想想看，成年后的最大庆祝活动大概是什么。
Like it's a wedding, right? But if you never get married, if you never have children or an anniversary or a significant other, who celebrates you? Who makes your important moments feel extra special, especially when everybody else begins to partner off? And they have their like one person. It can kind of feel like you're on the sidelines. It can feel like everything you do is secondary to the praise and the love and the excitement that you see people getting from their relationship. The other thing that this person spoke about that I think we don't speak about nearly.
比如是一场婚礼，对吧？但如果你从未结婚，如果你从未有孩子、纪念日或重要的一半，谁来为你庆祝？谁会让你重要的时刻感到格外特别，特别是当其他所有人都开始成双成对的时候？他们有他们所谓的“唯一”。这会让你觉得你好像被晾在了一边。你会觉得你所做的一切都次于你在人们的恋爱关系中看到的赞美、爱和兴奋。这个人谈论的另一件事，我认为我们在这种语境下讨论得远远不够，
enough in this context is the pressure of wanting to have children but feeling like you need to have a partner before you can do that. Especially for women, I feel like the older that I've gotten, the more conversations I've been having about fertility, about my biological clock, about things like egg freezing. And it's kind of like, is that future that I want for myself? Having children, is that going to be possible if I don't first achieve like the relationship? status that would afford that because that's how society has told me it needs to be done. So quite a few of you actually did message in about this experience. I'm going to use one more example. I'm going to take one more DM that I really, really liked. I found quite articulate
那就是渴望有孩子的压力，但又觉得在做到这一点之前你需要先有一个伴侣。特别是对于女性来说，我觉得我年龄越大，关于生育能力、关于我的生物钟、关于冷冻卵子之类的事情的对话就越多。这就有点像，那是我为自己想要的未来吗？如果我没有首先达成能够支持这一点的恋爱状态，生孩子还可能实现吗？因为社会就是这样告诉我必须要这么做的。所以你们中确实有相当多的人就这种经历发过私信。我将再使用一个例子。我将采用另一条我非常非常喜欢的私信，我觉得它表达得相当清晰，
about this sense of being the last one in the friendship group to be single. When I read download the dating apps, it feels like I am bait, not only to the worsening dating system, but as a prop some of my friends who are in relationships to comment on how I live vicariously through you or I'm so glad I'm not on the apps. I am just like my friends though. I'm a lover girl just without the relationship and I'm optimistic that I will find somebody. My 20s feel behind without somebody as a single person. I pay more to live. I feel lost and forgotten about when it comes to social activities. I'm not considered to be invited by my friends. I've lost friends who once were very happy to leave me to sit alone in a club whilst they all went away with their boyfriends. Yikes, those are bad friends.
关于这种成为朋友圈里最后一个单身的人的感觉。当我下载约会软件时，感觉自己就像诱饵，不仅是对日益恶化的约会系统的诱饵，而且是某些恋爱中的朋友们的道具，用来评论我是如何通过你获得代入感的，或者“我太高兴我没用这些软件了”。但我其实和我的朋友们一样。我是一个渴望爱情的女孩，只是没有恋爱关系，而且我很乐观，我会找到某个人的。如果没有伴侣作为一个单身的人，我的二十多岁感觉落后了。我生活的花费更高。在社交活动方面，我觉得自己被迷失和遗忘了。我甚至不会被朋友们考虑邀请。我失去了一些朋友，他们曾经很高兴让我独自坐在夜总会里，而他们却都和各自的男友一起玩去了。天哪，这些可不是好朋友。
Trust me, you didn't lose anybody worth having. But I think that really highlights some other really critical points, right? It's not just about love. It's not just about finding somebody in connection. It kind of relates to everything else in our lives, like finances, paying more to live as a single person. Like our friendships, feeling like as all of our friends find people, you're kind of excluded from the couple kind of relationships that people now have. So that is one experience when it comes to feeling behind in our relationships, the experience of inexperience and feeling like there is just such a huge part of your life that is missing, that you may never experience, you'll never know what people kind of write the songs about, why they say love is a drug. You just never get to feel cared for in
相信我，你没有失去任何值得拥有的人。但我认为这确实突出了其他一些非常关键的点，对吧？这不仅仅是关于爱。这不仅仅是关于寻找某人和建立联系。它实际上关乎我们生活中的方方面面，比如财务，作为一个单身人士支付更多的生活费用。比如我们的友谊，感觉当所有的朋友都找到了伴侣时，你某种程度上被排斥在了人们现在所拥有的情侣圈之外。所以，这就是关于在感情中感到落后的其中一种体验，即缺乏经验的体验，并且感觉你的生命中有一大块缺失了，你可能永远不会经历，你永远不会知道人们为什么会为爱写歌，为什么他们说爱情就像毒品。你只是永远无法以你一直以来所渴望的那种方式感受到被人关爱。
the way that you've kind of always wanted. It's more than a longing, I think. It becomes an insecurity that something must be wrong with you because everyone else has been able to have this experience has found at least to somebody who wanted to date them and you haven't. Trust me, it just hasn't happened yet. That's all. And that really, really sucks. And I'm really sorry that you feel like you're missing out because I can understand exactly where you're coming from. But I'm not going to give you some like bullshit reminder of like, don't worry, like it happens when you least expect it.
我认为这不仅仅是一种渴望。它变成了一种不安全感，觉得你身上一定出了什么问题，因为其他人都能拥有这段经历，至少找到了一个想要和他们约会的人，而你却没有。相信我，这只是还没发生而已。就是这样。这真的，真的很糟糕。我真的很抱歉，让你觉得你错过了什么，因为我完全能理解你的感受。但我不会给你灌输什么狗屁提醒，比如“别担心，在你最不经意的时候它就会发生”。
What I am going to say is that when it does happen, because it will happen, it's going to feel amazing. It's going to feel greater than all of your expectations. And I think that the moment that it does happen, you'll look back at where you are now and be like, what was I worried about? Why was I so stressed? You know, one of my best friends is 28 and she's never been in a relationship before. And I look at her and I honestly cannot comprehend why, because she is absolutely perfect. But sometimes it just goes that way. You just haven't crossed paths with the right person yet. You've, you know, you've been selective, you've held back. That's a good thing. You've been picky. But you will never be the last one standing, I promise. There's always going to be somebody else in the same boat
我要说的是，当它确实发生时，因为它是会发生的，感觉会棒极了。它会感觉比你所有的期待都要伟大。我想，就在它发生的那一刻，你会回过头来看现在的自己，然后会想：我当时在担心什么？我为什么那么紧张？你知道的，我的一个好朋友28岁了，她以前从未谈过恋爱。看着她，我老实说无法理解为什么，因为她绝对是完美的。但有时事情就是这样。你只是还没有和对的人交汇。你一直很挑剔，你有所保留。这是件好事。你一直很挑剔。但我向你保证，你永远不会是最后一个站着的人。总会有另一个人处于同样的境地，
who is navigating the same loneliness, the same insecurity, the same anticipation as you are. So the other group of people who I think struggle with feeling behind in their romantic relationships during the 20s is those of us who spent a big part of this decade or our early 20s with a single person who we kind of thought was the one, we'd never have to be single again, and then unexpectedly things go south and you break up. This was one person's experience and I really liked how they put it. I feel fine in other aspects of life except my relationship. In August, I ended a very long-term relationship with somebody that I lived
和你经历着同样的孤独、同样的不安全感、同样的期待。因此，我认为在二十多岁时在恋爱关系中苦于感到落后的另一类人，是我们中的那些在这一十年或二十岁出头的大部分时间里，都和一个单身的人在一起度过的人，我们曾以为那个人就是真命天子，我们再也不用单身了，然后意外地事情急转直下，你们分手了。这是一个人的经历，我真的很喜欢她的表达方式。除了感情，我生活中的其他方面都很好。八月份，我和一个同居了近三年的伴侣结束了一段非常长期的关系，原因非常充分。我感到非常落后，因为我非常渴望结婚生子。我现在26岁，是一名母婴护士。天哪，我们太爱受过良好教育的女性了。所以我一直都在看到新生儿和家庭。虽然我试着保持优雅和信念，但这只是重申了我有多么渴望它，以及我现在感觉自己落后了多少。我真的，真的很抱歉。
with for nearly three years due to very valid reasons. I feel so behind because I want to be married and have children so badly. I'm 26 now and I work as a mother slash child nurse. My gosh, we love an educated woman. So I see newborns and families all the time. Whilst I try and have grace and faith, it just reiterates how badly I want it and how behind I feel now. I am so, so sorry.
我简直无法想象，那种既充满喜悦、同时又无比痛苦的感觉会是怎样的，心里会想：哇，这对于这个新家庭和这个来到世上的新生命来说是一次多么不可思议的体验啊，但这却给我带来了巨大的痛苦，因为这正是我想要的。我认为这是导致落后感的一个巨大因素，那就是觉得你把所有事情都做对了，你拥有了恋情，你拥有了工作，你在积蓄、个人发展以及你对生活中想要的一切方面都做得很好，然后某些事情就像是从盲区里突然飞出来，把这一切都击倒了，你所有的计划、你所有谨慎的努力、你为了这段关系、为了创造你为自己想要的生活而付出的所有心血都化为乌有了，你不得不试着带着你意料之外的现实继续前行。这是在这个十年中发生的一件大事，当你知道不幸的是长期关系确实会结束时，那个你以为你要嫁的人，结果却只是一个配角，一个只是为了推动故事发展、给你上一课的人。所以我对这个人充满爱意，我也对那些正在经历这一切、不仅体验着心碎和悲伤、还要面对生活可能并不像他们希望的那样井井有条的新现实的其他所有人充满爱意。现在可能会有些事情被
I just cannot imagine how both like joyful and Simon simultaneously difficult that would be to be like, wow, like this is such an incredible experience for this new family and this like new soul that's in the world, but it brings me so much pain because that is exactly what I wanted. I think that's a huge contributor to feeling behind is feeling like you've done everything right, that you've got the relationship, you've got the job, you're doing great with your savings, with your personal development, with everything else you want in life. and then something kind of just like comes out of left field and knocks that all down and all of your planning all your cautious efforts all the work that you've put into this relationship that you've put
推迟了，突然之间你又开始感到落后了。当你想要寻找联结、寻找伴侣、寻找一个能陪伴在你身边和你一起成长的人时，你会觉得自己又回到了起跑线上。所以我们已经讨论了人们在二十多岁时感到落后的三个核心原因：事业、财务、爱情。现在我想快速梳理一下导致这种情况发生而我们尚未提及的一些原因。我知道我们之前已经讨论过一些促成因素，但我觉得还有一些关于感到落后的心理成分值得一提。当然，你们也分享了更多关于这方面的经历。所以首先，我们有外部压力。我们知道
into creating this life that you wanted for yourself is undone and you kind of have to find a way to move forward with the reality that you didn't expect that's a huge thing that happens during this decade when you know unfortunately long-term relationships do end the person that you think you were going to marry, turns out to just be somebody who was a secondary character, somebody who was just there to further the story along to teach you a lesson. So I have a lot of love for this person and I have a lot of love for the other people who are going through this, who are not only experiencing heartbreak and grief, but also a new reality that their life might not be as like all together as they wanted it to be. There may be things that are now
这出于爱意。但当生活中的每个人都在问我们想做什么、我们的梦想工作是什么、我们对未来的计划是什么、我们的约会生活怎么样、最近有没有遇到什么好人之类的问题时，这种期待感便开始堆积如山。我们突然觉得我们不仅是在为自己、为二十多岁的生活而活，也是为了别人而活。我们需要达到某种标准，不仅要让他们开心，还要让他们闭嘴，并让他们觉得我们过得很好，正在做他们期望的事。我也觉得“接下来做什么”这种心态相当困难，因为作为一个社会，我们非常关注势头，非常关注进步和成功。正因为如此，我们从不停下来驻足并专注于我们现在拥有的东西。
delayed and suddenly you're feeling behind again. You're feeling like you're back at the starting line when it comes to finding connection, finding a relationship, finding someone to kind of grow with you by your side. So we've spoken about the three core reasons that people feel behind in their 20s. Career finances love. I want to now go through a quick rundown of some of the reasons this happens that we haven't mentioned. I know we've kind of spoken about some of the contributing factors before, but there are some other psychological components to feeling behind that I think we deserve to mention. And you guys have of course shared even more of your experiences when it comes to this. So first off the bat, we have external pressure. We know that
这就好像我经常给出的一个例子：你苦读多年终于毕业了，紧接着人们就会问你找工作进展得怎么样。人们马上就会问：“那么接下来呢？你打算怎么过日子？全职工作什么时候开始？”如果你说：“哦，不，我还没完全找到合适的工作。”“哦，好吧，找到了通知我一声。看你需要帮忙吗？哦，你真的该抓紧找了，因为这需要时间。”这根本没用。你和你三年前的伴侣分手了，就像我们之前谈过的那个人一样。人们突然又开始担心你什么时候能重返约会市场。你知道的，时间在流逝。这是一个重要的问题。当我们如此专注于下一步是什么，如此专注于推动车轮向前、推动生活向前时，
it comes from a place of love. But when everyone in our life is asking us about what we want to do, what's our dream job, what are our plans for the future, how's our dating life going? Have we met anyone like nice recently, that sense of expectation really begins to pile up. We suddenly feel like we're not just living our life and our 20s for ourselves, but for others. And we need to meet some kind of like standard to not just make them happy, but to kind of get them to shut up and to kind of get them to feel like we're doing all right and we're doing what they expect. I also find that what's next mentality quite difficult because as a society we're very focused on momentum and we're very focused on progress and success. And because of that, we never stop pause and focus on what we have
我们从来没有真正的时间去消化我们目前的处境，去享受我们正在经历和正在学习的东西，去享受青春，享受我们现在的样子。我们再也回不去那个时候了。我想指出的最后一个我们尚未讨论过的因素，考虑到它的普遍性和普遍存在性，这其实很令人惊讶，那就是人们一直贴上标签的“疫情跳过期”。这种观点认为，对于我们这些在封锁中、在隔离中、在应对新冠疫情中度过了二十岁出头很大一部分时间的人来说，我们无法旅行。
now. It's kind of like an example I always give is you graduate after studying for years and years and years and immediately people are asking you how the job hunt is going. Immediately people are like, So what's next? What are you going to do with your life? When's the full-time work start? And if you're like, oh, no, I haven't quite found something yet. Oh, okay, well, let me know when you do. Let me know if you need help. Like, oh, you should really get looking because it takes a while. Like, it's not helpful. You know, you break up with your partner of three years like that person we spoke about before. And people are suddenly worried about when you're going to get back in the dating game. You know, the clock is ticking. That's the big one. When we are so focused on what's next and we're so
我们错过了那些重要的成型期事件，比如毕业典礼、比如亲身拥有第一份工作、比如出门结识新人和搬到新城市的契机。我们在成型期失去了大量的时间和经历。所以，是的，你可能25岁，你可能24岁、27岁，或者别的什么年龄。但实际上，因为你失去的那段时光，你感觉自己只有22岁或23岁。虽然你觉得你应该把一切都安排妥当，就像一个典型的25岁或27岁的人应该做的那样，但实际上你并没有把那段未来超出你控制而被推迟的整整一个篇章计算在内。
focused on pushing the needle forward, pushing our life forward. We never really have time to just process where we're at and to enjoy what we're experiencing and what we're learning and enjoy, like, the youth, enjoy who we are right now. We're never going to get that person back again. One final factor that I want to know that we actually haven't spoken about yet, which is surprising because of how ubiquitous and universal it is, is what people have been labelling. as the pandemic skip. This idea that for those of us who spent a lot of our early 20s in a lockdown, in quarantine, dealing with the COVID pandemic, we were unable to travel.
所以这就好像时间凝固了一样。你并没有真正按照10年前或更早10年前二十几岁的人会经历的那种方式去体验这个世界。所以，你不能因为自己在二十岁出头这个非常特殊的形成期里，没有机会出门去看看那些本该去见识的事物而过分责备自己，在这个时期我们确实拥有很多自由，并且对成长和体验有着更多的包容和开放性。所以，是的，就像我说的，给你的年龄减去几岁，把自己当作你实际上的那个真正的23岁或20岁年轻人来对待，稍微放自己一马。所以有人就此写信来，我真的很
We missed out on some of those big formative events like a graduation, like having our first jobs in person, like the opportunity to go out and meet new people to move cities. We lost a lot of time and experiences during our formative years. And so, yes, you might be 25, you might be 24, 27, whatever. But really, you're like 22 or 23 because of that time that you lost. Whilst you think that you should have it all together, like a typical 25-year-old should have or a 27-year-old, really you're not accounting for that whole chapter where your future was delayed beyond your control.
喜欢他们的视角。我二十几岁快过完了，最近我意识到我感到落后的部分原因是因为新冠。一切开始时我刚满24岁，由于墨尔本的封锁，我被困在了一份工作里，我的工作量和责任与我的薪水严重不对等，我错过了二十几岁中期本该有的社交、学习和成长的时光。所以现在我的处境还不错，但这并不是我两三年前以为自己会达到的地方。老实说，要接受这一点真的很艰难。这个人简直把我想说的话完美地表达出来了。人们不仅围绕着我们在二十多岁时应该取得的进步和我们应该达到的位置进行了大肆的炒作，而且还围绕着一些更有趣、更令人愉快的事情进行了炒作，这些事情为未来的经历奠定了基础。
And so it was kind of like time froze. you weren't really experiencing the world the way that 20-something year olds 10 years ago or 10 years before that would have experienced it. So you can't beat yourself up for some of the things that you just didn't have the opportunity to go out and see during that like really special formative time in our early 20s when we do have a lot of freedom when there is so much more capacity and openness to growth and experience. So yes, like I said, take a few years off your age, treat yourself like you are the real 23-year-old or 20-year-old that you actually are and give yourself a little bit of a break. So someone wrote in about this and I really
你知道，旅行总是最先浮现在我脑海里的例子。你知道为什么机票价格会飙升，特别是如果你来自澳大利亚的话，我觉得如果你去年试图去任何地方，价格基本上都是你平时预期的三倍。这有点像人们为了报复疫情期间无法旅行而进行的旅行，并以此弥补那些失去的体验。好了，我们花了很多时间讨论是什么导致了我们的落后感。但我觉得，无论是什么原因导致了这种停滞不前的感觉，你都得找到一种方法来管理它，对吧？我深信不凡的人生哲学是：生活已经够难了，你不需要因为自己按照自己的节奏前进、以不同的方式行事、没有达到某种无形的、奇怪的、社会强加的时间表而让自己感觉更糟。我非常坚定地这么说，但我觉得知道是一回事，真正贯彻这种信仰体系、这种漫不经心且走自己的路的态度则是另一回事。所以我们将
love their perspective. I'm in my late 20s and I've realized recently that part of my feeling behind is due to COVID. I had just turned 24 when everything started and because of the lockdowns here in Melbourne, I got stuck in a job who underpaid me for my workload and responsibility and I miss those mid-20 years of socializing, of learning and growing. So where I'm now is good, but it's not where I thought I'd be two to three years ago. It's been really tough wrapping my head around it honestly. Literally this person articulated it so, so perfectly. There is so much hype around not just the progress we should be making in our 20s and where we should be, but also some of the more fun things, the more enjoyable things that kind of set the foundation
进行短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，我们将讨论一些关于如何管理这种觉得自己人生落后、二十多岁落后的感觉的建议。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
for future experiences. You know, travel is the one that always comes to my mind. You know, the reason why airfare prices like jumped like through the roof, especially if you're from Australia, I feel like if you tried to go anywhere last year, it was like triple the amount that you would normally expect. It was kind of like people traveling as like revenge for when they couldn't travel during COVID
我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
and making up for those lost experiences. Okay, so we spent a lot of time talking. about what contributes to us feeling behind. But I think regardless of what's causing this sense of stagnation, you kind of have to find a way to manage it, right? Something I believe very deeply in life is that life is hard enough. You don't need to make yourself feel any worse for going at your own pace, for going about things differently, for not meeting some intangible, weird, socially imposed timeline. I say that very firmly, but I think knowing it is one thing, implementing this belief system and this attitude of nonchalance and going about it your own way is another. So we're going
也就是TWO%。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什到底跟小金有什么关系？
to go on a short break, but when we come back, we're going to talk through some tips on how to manage this sense that you are behind in life and behind in your 20s. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个时刻，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这一关的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊快克，只是为了让你们知道。我是说，到目前为止，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上台面了。谢谢你把这句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将结合我自己在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush
我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。
got to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种完全不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同层面的信任。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a deck. of my own experience in the middle health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前“钻石王老五”明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场 paternity 丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。
I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一支网络侦探大队来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·阿莱斯平（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，美利哥帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因涉嫌欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
心理健康心理学领域最大的治疗干预措施之一是认知行为疗法。你以前可能听说过它，但其前提是你可以通过首先纠正无益或有缺陷的思维方式，来改变你对自身境遇的负面情绪反应。它本质上是一种有意识的认知重塑，这样一来，你不再对情况抱有最坏的打算，不再预测自己会失败，不再对自己说那些伤人的、艰难的、刻薄的、自我怀疑的话语，而是重新定位它们，并将它们重新构建为积极的。因此，其基本前提是：如果你能改变你对某事的看法，你也会改变你对这件事的反应。所以，例如，不要去想：我没有达到我想要的高度，这让我成为了一个失败者。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini.
我永远无法到达我想去的地方。我总是会觉得自己落后。我永远不会拥有那个人所拥有的东西。相反，你应该将你的视角重新建构为更积极的事情。例如，你可以把你的旅程想象成你在走一条风景优美的路线。我们之前提到过这一点。你不仅仅是在生活的公路上飞驰。你不仅仅是一路上收集成就和里程碑却没有真正享受它们。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
你是在走风景优美的路线。你在信赖这个过程。你在海里停下来游个泳。你在和当地人聊天。你在收集那些当我们过于专注于产出时并不总是能制造出的特别回忆。我们太专注于把每件事都做到完美。我们太专注于跟上这种想象中的规范。重塑你对环境的认知的一部分，也围绕着专注于没有把一切都搞定的好处。
One of the biggest therapeutic interventions in the mental health psychology space is cognitive behavioral therapy. You have probably heard about it before, but the premise is that you can change your negative emotional reactions to your circumstances by firstly correcting unhelpful or faulty ways of thinking. It is essentially a conscious cognitive rewiring so that instead of thinking the worst of a situation, instead of predicting that you'll fail, instead of saying hurtful, hard, mean, self-doubting statements to yourself, instead you reposition them and you reframe them to be positive. So essentially the premise is if you can change how you think about something, you will change how you react to that thing as well. So, for example, instead of thinking, I'm not where I want to be, that makes me a failure.
所以这是一个我非常喜欢的关于这方面的贡献。我24岁，22岁大学毕业，这是美国大学毕业的平均年龄。我从未离开过美国，毕业后的这一个半天我都在旅行。天哪，太有趣了，一年半，简直太不可思议了。不过，我还是觉得我比那些毕业后直接从事全职工作的同龄人落后。从那以后我做过季节性工作和自由职业，并在包括澳大利亚在内的七个国家生活和旅行过。天哪，我太喜欢听这个了。但我还是无法摆脱那种在物质上落后的感觉。尽管我经历了难以置信的个人成长，找到了一段非常充实的感情，变得更加自信、自给自足，并反思了我在生活中想要的东西。
I'm never going to get where I want to go. I'm always going to feel behind. I'm never going to have what that person has. You instead reframe your perspective as something more positive. For example, you think about your journey like you are taking the scenic route. We've mentioned that before. You're not just kind of like zooming down life's highway. You are not just like picking up accomplishments and milestones on the way and not really enjoying them.
感觉美国尤其不重视为了旅行而旅行，这让我很难过，因为在外国弄懂公共交通和签证，让我获得的成长比我坐在大学阶梯教室里时要多得多。好了，首先，恭喜你，去了七个国家，这真是一个惊人的壮举。我尤其喜欢人们来澳大利亚，因为我知道它离世界上其他地方非常远，但它真的可以说是最美丽的国家，显然我有点偏心，但对此真正让我触动的是你拥有了这段不可思议的旅行经历，对吧？但你仍然觉得自己落后了，因为你所有的朋友都在走传统的路线，这对于他们来说很好。
You are taking the scenic route. You are trusting the process. You're stopping for a swim in the ocean. You're chatting to the locals. You're picking up special memories that we don't always make when we're so focused on output. We're so focused on doing everything perfectly. We're so focused on keeping up with this imaginary norm. part of reframing your cognitions towards your circumstances is also around focusing on the benefits of not having it all
他们上了大学，然后直接进入了职场。我敢打赌，你的很多朋友都在看着你的经历，心想：天哪，我真该请几年假。工作让我筋疲力尽。我从来没有给自己一个机会去真正享受我的空闲时间，享受一些假期。我在这里真正想说的是我们必须做出的权衡，特别是在我们二十岁出头的时候，那时有那么多的决定，有那么多的选择、那么多的选项以及过生活和过未来的不同方式，我们所做的每一个选择，确实都必须失去一些东西。
figured out so this was a contribution that spoke about this that I loved I'm 24 and I graduated from uni at 22 which is the average age to graduate in the US I'd never left the US and I've spent the last year and a half since graduating traveling oh my gosh that's so fun a year and a half that's like incredible. I feel so behind my friends though who graduated and hopped straight into full-time jobs. I've since done seasonal and freelance work and I've lived and traveled through seven countries, including Australia. Oh my gosh, I love to hear it. But I still can't shake the feeling that I'm behind in the material things. Even though I've had incredible personal growth, I found a really fulfilling relationship, I've become more confident, self-sufficient, and I've reflected on things that I want
但伴随着你失去的一切，你也确实得到了回报。这完全取决于你珍视什么。所以，是的，你可能会失去拥有一份排定好的工作的安全感，失去那种稳定性。但你可能也得到了更符合你心中真正珍视的东西。那可能是自由。那可能是灵活性。那可能是兴奋与成长。从你的经历中，你永远不会一无所获，即使它不是你所期待的，即使它没有按计划进行。我也认为，正视“草总是更绿的”哲学、草更绿综合症是很重要的。
in life. It feels like the US specifically doesn't value traveling for the sake of travel, which makes me really sad because I've had so much more growth trying to figure out public transit and visas in foreign countries than I ever did sitting in lecture halls at uni. Okay, right off the back, congratulations, seven countries that is an amazing feat. And I especially like when people come to Australia because I know it's very far from like everywhere else in the world, but it is like genuinely the most beautiful country ever, obviously I'm a little bit biased, but what really sticks out to me about this is the fact that you had this amazing experience traveling, right? But you still felt behind because all of your friends are doing the traditional route, which is great for them.
正如我所说，当你在看着别人的旅程并觉得自己与之相比有所欠缺时，他们可能也在看着你的旅程，并渴望拥有你所拥有的。仅仅因为你的道路不同，并不意味着它就低人一等，也不意味着它就不会成为其他人艳羡的源泉。所以我希望你更多地关注你所获得的，而不是你所失去的。是的，你可能失去了刚毕业时全职工作的稳定性。是的，你可能失去了一些这些人所拥有的财务安全感，他们有一个
They went to uni and they went straight into their jobs. I bet you some good money that a lot of your friends are looking at your experience and thinking, damn, I really should have just taken a couple years off. I am so burnt out by work. I really never gave myself a chance to actually enjoy my free time and to enjoy some time off. What I'm really speaking about here is the trade-off that we have to make, especially in our early 20s, where there are so many decisions, there are so many options, so many choices and different ways of going about life and going about our future, that with each choice we make, we do have to lose something.
所谓的“领先起跑线”。这并不意味着他们的道路从此就会一帆风顺，而你的道路就会充满坎坷。人们会遇到很多挫折、倒退、错误和障碍，这些必然会将我们所有人的道路推向与我们最初想象不同的轨道。仅仅因为他们在起跑后的头两年（毕业后的头两年）看起来进展非常顺利、非常按计划进行，并不意味着在五年后，
But with everything that you lose, you also do gain something in return. It's just about what it is that you value. So yes, you might lose that security of having a job lined up, that stability. But you also gain perhaps something that is more aligned with what you really value in life. That could be freedom. That could be flexibility. That could be excitement and growth. You are never not gaining something from your experiences, even if it's not what you expected. even if it's not going according to plan. I also think that it's important to confront the grass is greener philosophy, the grass is greener syndrome.
某人不会经历存在主义危机，然后说：“天哪，我其实从来没有真正享受过我生活中的任何一刻。”或者，“天哪，我其实从来没有给自己机会去真正思考我想要什么。我只是觉得有必要满足这种职业标准，好让事情有着落，有工作，有一种归属感，而现在我发现很难与之产生连接。”
Whilst you're looking at somebody else's journey, as I said, and feeling deficient in comparison, they may be looking at yours and wishing for what you have. Just because your path is different doesn't mean that it's inferior, doesn't mean that it's also not the source of envy for other people. So I want you to focus on what you have gained more than what you have lost. Yes, you may have lost the stability of a full-time job straight out of uni. Yes, you may have lost some of that financial security that these people had, you know,
并不是想说得太深奥，但是，你知道的，我们最终都会走到同一个终点。急什么呢？你想把有限的时间花在渴望走得更快、渴望有一个坚固的计划并且确切知道未来五、十年、十五年会带来什么上吗？这里面没有激情存在的空间。这里面没有惊喜的空间。这里面没有灵活性的空间。同样值得提醒你的是，如果你正处于二十多岁，而我假设
a quote-unquote head start at. That doesn't mean that their path is now forever going to be easy and that yours is going to be difficult. People come across a lot of upsets and setbacks and mistakes and barriers that will inevitably push all of our paths onto, you know, a different track than we initially thought. just because they've spent the first two years out of the gate, you know, the first two years after graduation, for them seemingly has gone very smoothly and very according to plan, doesn't mean that in five years' time,
你确实如此，你才刚刚开始。这是许许多多个十年、许许多多个季节和人生篇章中的第一个十年。想想你的人生。我以前用过这个比喻，但把它想象成一部电视剧，对吧？第一季并不是全部，他们不会在接下来的九季里把第一季一遍又一遍地重播。你的生活非常像这样。你正处于二十岁出头。你正处于二十多岁。
somebody isn't having an existential crisis and going, oh my God, I've actually never really enjoyed a moment of my life. Or, oh my gosh, I actually never gave myself the opportunity to really think about what I wanted. I just really felt the need to fulfill this career criteria to have something lined up, to have a job, to have a sense of purpose that, Now I'm finding it hard to connect to.
那是你电视剧的第一季。下一季将完全不同，再下一季也是如此，因为你一直在不断改变和演变。现在，你正处于实验阶段。你正处于不确定阶段。你正处于令人困惑的篇章中。许多人在你之前已经走过了这条朝圣之路。许多人都有过这样的经历。所以我希望你能通过一种正常感和社群感来抚慰你的怀疑和不安全感，让你知道你在这条路上并不孤单。其实就在几周前，我们请到了令人惊叹的梅格·杰伊（Meg Jay）博士来到播客中。你可能知道这个名字。她是一位非常非常著名的作家。她写了《人生的黄金年代》（The Defining Decade）。她是一位讲师。她
Not to get really extessential, but, you know, we all end up in the same place. What's the rush? Do you want to spend your limited time, wanting to be further ahead, wanting to have a solid plan and know exactly what the next five, ten, fifteen years will bring? There is no room for excitement in that. There is no room for surprise. There is no room for flexibility. It's also worth reminding you that if you are in your 20s and I'm assuming
话虽有点形而上学，但你知道的，我们最终都会去到同一个地方。那么急干什么呢？难道你想把有限的时间都花在渴望走得更前面、渴望有一个坚实的计划、并确切知道未来五、十年、十五年会带来什么上面吗？那样做就没有了兴奋的空间。没有了惊喜的空间。没有了灵活应变的空间。同样值得提醒你的是，如果你正处于20多岁——我假设
that you are, you are just getting started. This is the first decade of many, many, many decades and many, many seasons and chapters of life. Think about your life. I've used this analogy before, but think about it like a TV series, right? It's not like the first season is all there is and they just replay the first season again and again for the next nine seasons. Your life is very much like that. You're in your early 20s. You're in your 20s.
你确实在这个年纪——那你才刚刚开始。这是许许多多十年中的第一个十年，也是人生中许许多多季节和篇章的开始。想想你的人生。我以前用过这个比喻，但把它想象成一部电视剧，对吧？可不是说第一季就是全部，然后接下来的九季都在一遍又一遍地重播第一季。你的人生非常类似。你正处于20多岁的初期。你正处于20多岁。
That is the first season of your TV show. next season is going to be completely different, and so is the season after that, because you are constantly changing and evolving. Right now, you're in the experimentation phase. You're in the uncertainty phase. You're in like the confusing chapter. A lot of people have made this pilgrimage before you. A lot of people have had this experience. So I want you to kind of soothe your doubt and soothe your insecurity through a sense of like normalcy and through a sense of community that you are not alone in this. A couple weeks back actually we had the amazing Dr. Meg Jay on the podcast. You might know that name. She is a very, very famous author. She wrote The Defining Decade. She is a lecturer. She is
那是你电视剧的第一季。下一季将完全不同，接下来的那一季也是如此，因为你一直在改变和进化。现在，你处于实验阶段。你处于不确定阶段。你处于类似于令人困惑的篇章中。在你之前，有许多人已经经历过这段历程。许多人都有过这样的经历。所以我希望你能通过一种正常感和社群感来抚平你的怀疑和不安全感，让你知道在这条路上你并不孤单。实际上，几周前我们请到了了不起的梅格·杰伊博士（Dr. Meg Jay）来到播客。你可能知道这个名字。她是一位非常非常著名的作家。她写了《二十多岁决定的人生》（The Defining Decade）。她是一位演讲者。她是
a really spectacular psychologist. And she was telling me about how when she was in her mid, mid to late 20s. Right after university, she was working as an outward bound instructor. She was literally spending her days paddling through a swamp, showing like tourists and, you know, people around nature. That is so different to what she is doing now. And I'm sure that whilst, you know, I can't speak for her, but I'm sure that while she was doing this, she was watching people she knew go to grad school. She was watching people she knew win awards and have kids and set up their own businesses. But the thing is, is that now at the age she is at, she is still in a really good place. And I'm sure those other people are as well, but just because her journey wasn't exactly
一个非常出色的心理学家。她跟我讲述了她在二十岁中期，大概是二十五到二十九岁的时候。大学毕业后不久，她当过户外拓展教练。她每天的日子几乎都是在沼泽里划船，带带游客什么的，带着大家体验大自然。这跟她现在做的事情太不一样了。而且我敢说，虽然我不能代表她，但我确信，当她在做这些事情的时候，她看着自己认识的人去读了研究生。她看着认识的人获奖、生孩子、创立自己的公司。但关键在于，现在的她，到了这个年纪，依然过得非常不错。我相信其他人也是如此，只是因为她的人生轨迹并非完全
the way that it needed to be, doesn't mean that she didn't end up getting to a place where she was really fulfilled. And another component of that is that all those experiences that I'm sure she was like, dang, I really wish I was doing something else. I really wish that my life had turned out differently. Those experiences are probably really, really valuable now. And they're the kind of experiences that possibly contribute, you know, massively to all of her incredible ideas and her writing that she may not have had if she'd taken yet again the traditional route. There's nothing wrong with that route. It's just that it's not the only way to go about it. In terms of feeling behind in your relationship, I want to talk about my friend Katie,
按照预期的那样发展，并不意味着她最终没有到达一个让她真正感到满足的境界。其中的另一个部分是，我相信她当时一定觉得，天哪，我真希望自己在干点别的，我真希望我的人生能有所不同，而所有这些经历，现在看来可能都极其极其宝贵。正是这些经历，可能对她所有那些不可思议的想法和写作做出了巨大的贡献，如果她当初走了传统路线，这些经历或许根本不会有。传统路线本身没有什么问题，只是它并不是唯一的选择。说到在感情方面觉得落后，我想聊聊我的朋友凯蒂，
another guest that we had on the show. She met her first boyfriend at 27, almost when she was 28 and now she is in this wonderful relationship. In the episode that I did with her, she really speaks quite vulnerably about how difficult it was to be at that age and feel like she was missing out on this huge component of a fulfilling happy life, which was love. But, you know, she took time to learn herself. She had the experiences with people that, you know, didn't work out. she had time to make beautiful fulfilling friendships to move cities to do all those things and she ended up
她是我们的另一位节目嘉宾。她27岁才遇到她的第一任男友，当时差不多28岁了，而现在她正处于一段美好的感情中。在那期我和她合作的节目里，她非常敞开心扉地谈到，在那个年纪却觉得自己在错过幸福美满生活中的一个重大组成部分——也就是爱情——是多么艰难的一件事。但是，你知道的，她花时间去了解自己。她经历过那些最终没有结果的人际关系。她有时间去建立美好而充实的友情，搬去不同的城市，做所有这些事情，最终她
in this like incredible relationship with this amazing person and she said something really profound which is that she looks back at it now and she can appreciate that it was hard but it really felt quite worth it so there's another example and you know because we're on a bit of a role I'm also going to include my mom and this as somebody who you can think of and feel better about yourself. When she was in her 20s, she literally got kicked out of like every single course that she did. She failed her first degree. She was asked to leave by her old university faculty. She was working at a restaurant for years whilst her friends, you know, got scholarships and became doctors and nurses. But she took her time. And when she felt ready, she went back to
收获了一段极其美妙的感情，和一个非常了不起的人在一起。她说过一句非常深刻的话，那就是她现在回过头来看，能够体会到过去虽然艰难，但确实非常值得。所以这是另一个例子。既然我们状态正佳，我还要把我的妈妈也算进去，把她当作一个能让你想起并对自我感觉好一点的榜样。在她二十多岁的时候，她几乎被她上的每一个课程都劝退了。她的第一个学位挂科了。她被老东家的大学院要求离职。她在一间餐馆打工好几年，而她的朋友们却拿了奖学金，成了医生和护士。但她不慌不忙。当她觉得自己准备好了，她就回到了
university. She's now a CEO. She now literally runs a company. She is like an incredible woman. She raised three daughters. She has like an army of beautiful, beautiful friends and she's really successful. And I'm sure that when she was in that phase where it wasn't working out, where all she could think was about her failures and everything that hadn't been a success, she wouldn't have been able to picture where she is now. I think we really need to start glamourizing. and sharing the success stories of people who didn't have it straightforward. And reminding ourselves that just because it's taking a bit longer doesn't mean you won't get there eventually.
大学。她现在是一名首席执行官。她现在真的在运营一家公司。她是个了不起的女性。她抚养了三个女儿。她有一大群美丽动人的好朋友，而且非常成功。我敢肯定，当她处于那种诸事不顺的阶段，满脑子都是失败以及所有未能成功的往事时，她是绝对无法想象自己能有今天的。我觉得我们真的应该开始美化和分享那些人生并非一帆风顺的人的成功故事。并且提醒自己，仅仅因为花的时间稍微长一点，并不意味着你最终无法到达终点。
And even if you don't get to where you imagined you would be, in the time that you wanted to do it, you can still feel happy in whatever circumstances you find yourselves in. I want to remind you of just the resilience of humans and the fact that people find great joy and great strong. strength and something to live for and beauty and excitement, even in situations that they never could have anticipated. So even if it isn't going according to plan, it doesn't mean that the end result isn't going to be amazing. There's one final thing I want to say on this and it's actually
而且，即使你没有在想要的时间里达到你想象中的地方，无论身处何种境况，你依然可以感到快乐。我想提醒大家的是人类的韧性，人们总能在那些做梦也想不到的情境中，发现巨大的快乐、顽强的力量、生活的意义、以及美丽与激情。所以，即使事情没有按计划进行，也不代表最终的结果不会惊艳。关于这一点，我最后还有一句话要说，其实它
a quote. And I actually saw it on Reddit when I was doing some investigating for this episode. And it was a very well-known quote, which is that youth is wasted on the young. I think this exact situation we're talking about goes to demonstrate that quite well. A lot of people who are in their mid 30s, late 30s now, early 40s, all look back at their 20s and think, oh my God, why was I so worried? You know, I think we have a lot of hype around doing it all in this decade, but this is when we're making the least amount of money. We feel very stuck. We're not completely sure of ourselves. All the experiences that we should be having are wasted on us because we don't know how to appreciate them. We don't have the hindsight of knowing that it's all going to work out. So trust our elders, I guess,
是一句名言。我在为这期节目做调查时，其实是在红迪网（Reddit）上看到了它。这是一句非常著名的名言，那就是：青春总是挥霍在年轻人身上。我觉得我们正在讨论的这种情况，正好很好地诠释了这句话。很多现在三十岁中期、三十岁后期、甚至四十岁初的人，回首自己的二十岁时都会想：天哪，我当年为什么那么焦虑？你知道的，我觉得社会对在十年里搞定一切有着过度的炒作，但偏偏这也是我们赚钱最少的时候。我们感到非常迷茫。我们并不是完全了解自己。我们本该经历的所有人生体验都被我们白白浪费了，因为我们当时根本不懂得如何去欣赏它们。我们没有事后诸葛亮的视角，不知道一切最终都会迎刃而解。所以，我想我们还是去相信长辈们吧，
trust the people that have come before us who say time and time again, don't worry too much. It's all going to be okay. I feel like when I think about their experiences and their advice, it always brings me a real sense of inner peace. So thank you so much for listening to this episode. If you have made it this far, please DM me on Instagram and I'm going to send you a big, fat love heart to say thank you for putting up with my rambling. I know that this episode is a little bit different to what we usually do. I loved being able to incorporate some of your anecdotes, some of your experiences, and just be a little bit more fluid with it. I appreciate you listening this far. And if you did enjoy this episode, please feel free to give the podcast a five-star review
相信那些曾经走在我们前面的人，他们一次又一次地说：别太担心，一切都会好起来的。每当我想到他们的经历和建议，内心总是会涌起一股真正的平静。非常感谢大家收听本期节目。如果你听到了这里，请在Instagram上私信我，我会送你一个大大的红心，以此感谢你忍受了我这番絮絮叨叨。我知道这一期节目和我们平时的风格稍微有点不同。我非常喜欢能够融入你们的一些趣事和经历，让内容变得更加灵动一些。感谢你听到了最后。如果你确实喜欢这一期节目，请不要吝啬，给播客打个五星好评吧，
on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. Make sure you're following or you're subscribed based on what platform you're listening. And share this episode with a friend who you think might also be feeling a little bit stuck, feeling a little bit behind, feel like a problem shared, it's a problem halved. And it probably will make every person in that situation feel a little bit less alone and take the pressure off, take the foot off the gas for a little while. So thank you so much for listening. Until next episode, stay safe and be able to.
无论你是在Apple Podcasts、Spotify还是其他任何地方收听。请确保你根据自己使用的平台进行了关注或订阅。把这期节目分享给你觉得可能也感到有些迷茫、有些落后、或者觉得说出来就能减半烦恼的朋友。这大概能让身处那种情况的每个人都感觉不那么孤单，从而卸下压力，暂时松一口气。非常感谢大家的收听。直到下一期节目，保重身体，保持
kind and we'll talk soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
善良，我们很快再聊。嘿，各位最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难抉择》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主播基尔·盖姆斯。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披盔甲。它向世界传递出的信号是：别想惹我。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在iHeart广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难抉择》。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你把这个特定的测试篡改了两次之多，对吧？我篡改测试了一次。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我简直惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern. and worry. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier,
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这里是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的推进，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。这就是当电梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析精神坚韧、体能以及在我们这个奇特现代社会中培养韧性的科学。和担忧。经历一些艰难险阻，你就会迎来一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
更有成就感、更健康的自己。请在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即便是TWO percent。当一群女性发现她们约会的竟是同一个声名狼藉的诈骗犯时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应得的下场。我们总说要相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。